i'm gonna share this afternoon section
that there is a little bit more of uh
optimal transport
so like first marco couture is gonna
talk about uh computational ot
and later there is yamas
talking about the discrete and quantum
optimum transport
so both the speakers are in europe so
both uh
both blocks are going to be remote
so
marco
thank you very much for for
the presentation are you planning to
come here at a certain point in the
semester
uh yeah i was planning to come here but
i was not keeping track enough of the
the regulations and i realized too late
that i could have applied for a for an
exemption and so i started the bomb
emading the embassy but i didn't get an
answer
well thank you so much
okay thank you very much so i'm very
sorry about not being there with you
i feel a bit like a late night you know
radio host
just talking with
with the audience about some confessions
or something so
it's definitely very clear a very
different vibe from the usual one so
it's it's 11 p.m here but i'm very happy
to to give this a presentation today and
i really want to thank the organizers
for inviting me
so uh
i also mentioned earlier that you might
want to ask questions of course and i i
very much welcome any type of question
uh this will help me stay awake and make
sure i'm not
going to some
in necessary directions
so
this is this is going to be a one hour
presentation so there's going to be a
lot of content
but
i what i want to stress here is the
computational challenges that have
arisen from using optimal transport in
practice
and by practice as here i will be mostly
speaking about
practice in machine learning and
statistics
meaning probability distributions which
are
most often
high dimensional uh this might be like
5 d equals 5 10
20 50
and then a lot of data points and so
those challenges uh are
first to compute optimal transport and
if you look at the
the title here i'm talking about
differentiable matchings
and mappings and so this the idea is not
only here to compute transport and
compute this maybe optimal coupling or
optimum wash map but also to
differentiate through this through this
coupling meaning if i change the
measures or the the sampling measures
what happens to the coupling itself
so um
i'm going to start with an example i
hope philippe is in the room because
this is mostly derived from his work
yes okay he's raising the hand so he's
probably going to recognize this idea
imagine you have a you know biopsy you
know to take some tissue grab some cells
maybe those are tumor cells or healthy
cells and you want to
watch them over time you know as they
grow you have this dish and you just
try to look at it every six hours or so
what is amazing is that the current
state of technology in genomics allows
us to actually
look at the state of one single cell
people call it singleton genomics and so
i'm not going to pretend i'm a biologist
what is basically
given to us as machine learning or
statisticians
is a vector of features that describes
the cell at that point in time so
typically that might be the gene
expression levels and things like that
one of the challenges though is that you
can't take a cell you know from the
plate take its features and then put it
back and then see six hours later what
that cell has become so what you're
basically left with is this situation
where you're looking at a bunch of cells
the population of cells are time zero
you're going to sample a few of them so
this is your your sample of cells you're
going to put them through this machine
sequencing machine that is going to
featurize somewhat each of those cells
and in that process you're going to kill
the cell of course
and this gives you a picture of the
population of cells at time zero which
is which is a bunch of points out
basically
and then what you do typically is you
wait six hours more maybe you add some
reactants and things that you want to i
mean including the system and then
you're going to be again left with the
option of taking those a bunch of cells
maybe that number is the same or it's
going to be bigger let's assume for a
second it's the same
and so you're going to again you know
have this point cloud but right now it's
a point cloud that represents
the population a bit later
and so what what biologists are are are
confronted with is typically we would
like to understand what is the
individual trajectory of a cell what's
if you are a cell that at times you had
this kind of characteristics
what is typically going to happen to you
six hours later
but of course you can't replicate that
that experiment and so what you
end up doing is the closest natural gas
that i would say and that's basically
going to evolve some form of
optimal matching you're going to pretend
well i had blue cells you know like this
those are where my blue sets here six
hours later something happened nature
you know
continued and so the cells have grown i
would like to somewhat have a good guess
of what this type of cell might have
become
and so what you do is just simply look
for the optimal matching and so here
i'm going to be a bit vague
or if you if you if you go back to
previous lecture i would say it's more
like a a um
a kind of mulch map that you want to to
find that would help you tell you well
basically this cell became this one the
cell became this one etc etc so this is
roughly really at a very basic level
there the contribution of of the paper
that is on the lower left that's philly
contributed to
and uh i'm saying roughly because
there's a lot more to this
uh typically uh the challenges are that
the number of cells maybe is not the
same you have to account for some type
of type of growth in in in in the in the
cell population and other things
but roughly
what optimal transport is going to help
you here is to
disambiguate the step it's going to
remove the ambiguity of
guessing what cell became what cell
and just let me just do a bit of plug
for for some recent
effort in my team to to package software
that is able to do this at scale
we have developed a
software called alt optimal transport
tools and this is one of the if you're
interested in this application you can
of course look at phillips paper
and
and then
you can also check our
fairly simple implementation of these
ideas so this is with just one example
and i'm not going to go into the details
of there's lots more advanced
more advanced topics in in that line
another
area where this idea of computing and
matching
arises is in fairness when you want to
do classification that it's going to be
a bit mindful and careful about some
protected attributes so typically let me
let me show you a scenario where you
want to predict something
out of individual features so you have
some excise people
and why i something that you want to
predict this could be you know a loan or
maybe a health outcome or something like
that
and let's keep it simple let's assume
it's going to be a binary decision
so the the the idea of using empirical
risk minimization is going to be let's
try to find one
function f parameterized by theta
which for every x i is more or less
going to match what you have observed
and by
to do so typically you would minimize
some kind of so basically the average
risk
in doing so what happens
is if you are completely
you know
focused on minimizing the sum
you might find a parameter theta
which is such that of course you will
make some errors on some individuals so
maybe the error is going to be
distributed across the individuals in
the way picture below
and the error of course going to be
maybe bigger and smaller in some some
individual cases and then later what you
realize is that you are doing more
systematically errors in subpopulation
let's say this is the greens compared to
the purples on the left and to highlight
this i've just
plotted for instance the the histogram
of errors
uh between in the left population in the
right population
so here again
one of the ideas that has
emerged recently
is to enforce some kind of first
fairness mechanism that would be
operating
on this level basically at the level of
the distributions themselves so you
would say for instance a fair
classification for a loan
would be such that for instance
the distribution of errors done on the
purple population is more or less
similar to the distribution of errors
done on the greek population and at the
same time this might be for instance
uh you could even say i'm going to
enforce like the median error is the
same
on the on the purple and on the green
and there's other works and this is
really a string a lot of works recently
that have looked at this idea of using
optimal transport for fairness
other people for instance insist on
saying that a fair treatment would be
one where a median person
whatever that means in the green group
is more or less treated equally to the
median person in the purple group
and so again you will need to do this
type of matching either in one dimension
for simply just simply to match the
errors
or
of the population against the other to
say that
okay maybe if you are a university and
you want to hire
students from uh a country a and country
b
then a fair treatment would might be to
say that you're treating equally you
know the median student in country aid
and that you're treating the median
student in country and therefore you
need to have this kind of matching
there's lots of
okay this this is one example that we've
covered in the toolbox there are lots of
examples like this where the matching
the step intermitted step of matching
appears naturally as a way to help you
basically learn something more
complicated i have other examples in
neuroscience where for instance you
would do some form of registration of
the data when you have different brain
activation maps everybody has a
different you know brain and when we
have some stimulus
we might have a different area
from of the of the cortex which is
activated
uh but still we want to be able to do
this matching to say that to to have
something that is comparable and let me
just also illustrate an example that
comes from domain adaptation machine
learning a typical problem where you
have data
which is labeled you have you know red
and blue
points
and then you have a bunch of not labeled
data sets this is something that
you have you will probably try your
classifier on later on
but you don't have labeled data for it
and so one one idea that has been
in the air in the last
four or five years or so is basically
try to match do some kind of matching
between what you have in the train which
is labeled and what you will have in
this other data set this involves doing
some kind of optimal transport then you
are going to transport the labels
and then learn some
classifiers
so this is a bit of a
mix of problems where
essentially
an intermediate matching or mapping or i
could almost say coupling since you're
familiar already with the
with vocabulary of optimal transport
is going to be needed
to help you disambiguate
uh there is a strong prior that exists
on what a such a matching or mapping or
coupling might look like
and that prior is typically going to be
what i would expect to be
a matching should be have a low cost
so this is this is the main ingredient
in in deciding you know when you have a
ground cost what is the optimal matching
to to solve the optimal transport
problem
and what i think is interesting in the
machine learning perspective on optimal
transport is that
it is rarely the case that this matching
or coupling or mapping
is really the end goal
i would say that in the earlier
literature on optimal transplant
applications to data sciences maybe
doing that matching was enough
this was this was uh
sufficient maybe for for a given task i
would say that in the recent years
uh the focus is no longer really on
computing the coupling itself but rather
parameterizing that optimal coupling as
a function of you know the cost
parameters or some representations of
the data that you you can you can tune
in order to basically minimize some kind
of loss
after that so it's going to be important
not only to compute optimal transport
it's also going to be important to
differentiate through it
and so if you look at this
i haven't used too many you know
keywords from the the optimal transfer
literature uh
the biology example actually
is i think can be understood by anyone
without any background in optimal
transport and so when you start digging
into what you need to actually provide
this set of tools
well you realize that it's great to have
you know a toolbox that is guided by
theory
that is
robust and versatile to to accommodate
different types of data sets
it will need to be scalable so this is a
typical challenge that that we've been
facing in the last five or ten years
and uh the the differentiability is i
would say a more recent addition maybe
in the two or last three years and that
toolbox that theory is basically optimal
transport
and so
what is i find remarkable in the field
is that many of the challenges that have
been enumerating
uh
were
covered in mathematics
with a lag you know five or ten years
ahead so differentiability for instance
is a clear one
but every time you want to actually
adapt it and make it work you know real
data
there's a
whole new sort of challenges that arise
at the same time so it's one of those
fascinating fields i feel where there's
a confluence of
of interest
and
so just to illustrate this maybe
it's it's well known that this field is
super important in economics and
historically this was the development of
of of this theory
uh and it has spanned a lot of attention
it's found a lot of developments in
applied math pure maths and again a
small
plug for for a recent work with uh with
my
uh my colleague gabriel pereira uh we've
we've been focusing more on the
numerical issues in in the last uh years
with with this book
uh which does is a bit of a survey but i
have to say that this this survey is now
almost two years old now so it feels a
bit outdated in some respects so
we probably need to refresh it pretty
soon
um
so uh i think you've you've had this
wonderful introduction this morning to
uh to optimal transport so i will start
directly basically from where uh
you you you left you you you ended the
course
and there is this is basically
the definitions of
the various definitions of optimal
transport so it's already a bit
complicated
because
as you can see depending on on your
interest you might have various
various definitions of what constitutes
optimal transport so the the two
classical ones i would say
are the morse formulation and the
contour of each primal formulation
so this if of a t that pushes forward mu
to do of this integral of the cost of
the displacement
uh the other one of course is the
control visual potential so i think
i have more or less
the same notations that mikhail's
slides except that here i think she was
using a gamma here
uh where i was here i would be using a b
and uh
and i don't know what the dual
formulation was what the dishes were was
for her
for her dual problem this i will use
those notations in the continuous
setting
is there any question at this point
you use minus t and minus t
okay so in here you mean
for the dual yeah
yeah yeah i i i guess this is yeah
uh this
was it for the the squadron distance
cost or for the the general cost
for general cost
okay okay yes sometimes you will see an
f minus a five minus psi and things like
that
here i would just you be using a plus
apart from that everything sounds okay
yes
okay good
so
um
so as i said the lecture is going to be
short so i have to speed up a bit
already
i'm going to focus on my matters too and
i here i have to write maybe ml
stats you know practitioners
okay
it's not going to be a lecture on let's
say
applying you know looking at optimal
transport from the perspective of gases
in 3d or fluids
or let's say reflectors for to design
your
the lights of your car
there are lots of applications in
optimal transport are fairly low
dimensional
where what i'm going to say right now
does not apply necessarily i mean you
can argue but as soon as you start you
know dealing with with data sets which
are large and in higher dimensions than
two or three
then i would argue
that what a typical practitioner of
optimal transport or machine learning
statistics
would want to is to have the following
setup
we have samples
uh x1 and xn y1 and ym let's say so here
i'm just on purpose using a small
different quantity here
and so i'm going to
be
i will have to deal with empirical
measures
so a bunch of data
and what i want to do is typically
compute this quantity
these three quantities
on actual empirical measures
and this means
either focusing on the quantity itself
or
also maybe
focusing on the t star
the p star here and the five star
[Music]
psi star okay
so i want to compute either the optimal
transfer cost or the solutions in either
of those three settings and so
in in that scenario
what a practitioner would
clearly ask is how expensive is it to
compute this quantity
that you just gave me earlier in the
slide
and maybe if you are interested in deep
learning and end-to-end learning models
as is now really dominant
how can you differentiate through this
and if you're a statistician
or even just a practitioner for that
matter
you might also have you know
like the second order question would be
how meaningful would be that computation
compared to having access to the entire
distribution if i had access to the
entire mu u does it actually make any
sense
to work hard to compute the distance or
the solutions to this optimal transfer
problem between samples
if can i compare it with what i would
know in theory if i had access to entire
distributions so those are two questions
i think that that that are important
and uh whatever you you will need to
sell optimal transport to to a different
community
this is clearly the the two things that
people will ask so
again
ml stats i will assume that i have
access to points so in the first setting
in the march problem
uh well this arises when you want to
compare for instance the two point
clouds that i told you earlier in
biology so you have let's say
a hundred points you know
that describe a hundred cells and then
later because this is going to be a
morse map so we're going to assign one
to the other
we're going to assume there's 100 100
points on the right hand side
was there a question though i guess
so
in that case if you just
plug really the definition so it can
either be this definition or this
definition
if you plug i know either of these
definitions you have something which is
simplified
to the optimal assignment problem which
is simply a question of finding an
optimal permutation
and it's simply going to be finding an
optimal way that is going to sign one
point of the red measure to one point of
the blue measure
and we have decent algorithms for this
one of the most famous algorithms for
this problem
is called the hungarian algorithm
which was discovered in the early 20th
century and then redis represented later
in the 50s
and
what we essentially know is that this is
roughly cubic
when you implement it and there are
cases where this could be brought down
the complexity can be brought down a bit
further if you start assuming things on
the cost structure for instance
so already you can see that i mean the
cubic you know
exponent is is starting to pop up
and uh what
typically we
we would want to do in a more general
setting
not only covering the mulch problem but
rather covering the cattle rich problem
of finding a coupling is essentially
solving this
cartridge problem
even further the coupling blah blah blah
for those two measures and so if you
again directly plug this definition here
with the data that i just provided here
this is the mu this is the new
then what you have you just need to
write it down is the following problem
it's going to be
comparing the two measures and somewhat
isolating what i would call the geometry
of the problem
the one thing that only focuses on the
cost
between one point x i and one point y j
so this is this is basically going to be
your cost information
from every red point you're going to
look at every
blue point and this is going to give you
an n times n matrix
and then
the other thing is just the constraints
of the the mass conservation constraints
which are such that you essentially want
to
have a look at all matrices of size
n
times m
okay
such that the row sums
coincide with the weights that you are
given
a one a n
and the column sums
the column sums of this matrix p
must coincide with the weights b1
bm
that you have that you were given okay
so we have two measures
weights a weights b locations x location
y's
we split x and y we take a and b the
weights apart
x and y help us define
the cost matrix a and b help us define
the feasible set of of matrices and then
we are essentially going to just run a
linear program on this
we are just going to look at the matrix
p that satisfies this mass conservation
constraint with the smallest dot product
with
the the matrix of of of distances or cos
so far so good
okay so let me just
before we dive a bit
more into this problem
say that of course the remember the a
few slides ago i mentioned this dual
problem the controvic dual problem which
is about
potentials optimizing two potentials
such that the integral of each potential
against each measure is maximized
with the constraint here
i didn't really write this this this
very clearly but this means basically
that phi of x
plus
a psi of y
is going to be uh smaller than c
of x
and y
okay
oops sorry
so this this is the constraint so if you
again
simply just re-instantiate this dual
problem
on the two measures that i gave you here
like this
then what you just have is this
dual problem
which is going to maximize so this is
playing the role
you could almost write it as a as a phi
vector
this is going to be a psi vector okay
and you're going to integrate against
the measure so you're just going to sum
up values the values of alpha the
smallest of beta
and then you have this this dual
constraint on the cost
and uh what is i think important to
to uh to have an idea of is that
essentially the reason why we have the
dual problem
is because we want to have guidance
on what is basically causing this
optimal transport to be expensive or not
and this is going to play a role later
in the when we are going to try to
differentiate so let me try to give a
more concrete uh
explanation
so here i'm going to let's say
solve the optimal transport problem the
primal one the one
that we're used to between two measures
this is the blue and the and the red as
usual
and this is going to be a matrix of size
so here we have one two one two three
four five six
so n is equal to six
here we have one two three four
targets so m is equal to four
so the matrix
the optimal transport matrix is going to
be this
six times four matrix
like this
it's going to have a few non-zero values
and the non-zero values are exactly here
pictured as uh lines that connect one
red to one
so this is what you get when you solve
the optimal transfer problem in the
primal form
you have basically this idea of uh
transfers of masses between between
inputs and targets
what you have
uh if you solve the dual problem of
course it's something completely
different it's no longer an idea of
interactions between the inputs and the
targets
it's just simply a set of values which
is indexed by each of the points in your
measures
so for each of the six red points we
have six values and for each of the six
the four red blue points we have four
values and let me just plot you actually
the actual output
uh the of of this optimal dual problem
so what you have here is essentially
those six
values so i've plotted the values at
their points at the locations and to
plot uh those values i'm using a color
coding basically
and here
i'm doing the same thing for the blue
the four blue ones okay so i'm going to
move this
so what you can notice here is the
following
so first
the there is a
an environment with respect to a
constant factor
meaning if i raise all of the values of
the of the alpha you know the dual
variable for the first measure by a
constant and decrease it by
the same constant to the blue measure i
will have the same objective and i will
also satisfy the constraint so therefore
there is an invariance to to to to an
additive constant so you should look at
this values here relative to each other
not really as an absolute in absolute
terms
what you can see on the right hand side
is that
those those red values here
are i mean the values here for the red
points are essentially starting at the
lower bottom minus 4 ish
and then go up to let's say zero here so
the largest dual variable
is this value here
for the first for the input measure
and for the target measure the blue of
course is here just in convention
because in the counter range problem
everything is symmetric but the target
blue measure
the highest value is reached uh typical
basically here on those points here
because this corresponds to the whites
of the color map
and essentially the lower ones are
reached uh here in the middle
so what you can see is a pattern where
relative to each other
the highest values
for
the the input measure
are found here and the highest values
for the tackle measure are found here
and what this is exactly
actually telling you is some form of
sensitivity analysis this is well
understood in linear programming
this is basically telling you
uh there is a price to pay for each unit
of mass which is right now available in
each of the points that i'm
plotting here and that price to pay
you know if you were to simulate some
kind of mechanism to fix the price
of the optimal transport cost between
the blue and the red measure would be
those values and what you very clearly
see is that the largest values
are happening in those points which are
a bit further away
in the transport so intuitively on the
right on the left hand side you can see
that this is actually going to be a bit
painful in terms of transporting things
from red to blue
but what this is really quantified in
the dual problem here on the right hand
side
so
imagine for instance the red
distribution is a distribution of let's
say uh bakeries
and blue distribution is the
distribution of stores or like
restaurants that need the bread
if you were a planner and you wanted to
change the distribution of
either bakeries or restaurants to
minimize the transportation cost
well this is typically where you should
be looking at
you should be looking at this drawing to
say well it seems that
if i had to decrease the production of
one bakery it would probably be this one
and if i have to decrease for instance
the
amount of bread that is needed from
restaurants it would probably be the one
on the lower left
on the other hand
if i want to change the locations of the
bakeries in the restaurants
i should probably look at this thing
here
because this is going to tell me
basically that maybe this bakery needs
to move a bit further
closer to
this this restaurant it's serving
currently and vice versa
okay so this was a bit of a
bit of intuition you know on the primal
angle problems and what they provide you
in terms of
sensitivity
now
so so far i've
mentioned you know this is a linear
program
it's easy that's we can solve it so the
truth is that it is indeed uh relatively
easy so let's if you look at this from a
geometric perspective
this here you are let's say in the space
of matrices of size r n times m
and among those matrices you have a a
convex poly type of matrices that
satisfy the
the marginal constraints
and you have one
vector
which is summarizing again the geometry
of your problem
and this tells you everything about you
know the transportation cost and of
course the goal here is to find the
coupling that is going to minimize
the cost
the dot product and this is going to be
here this p star in this example
so uh
if you just want to address this problem
in full generality you make no
assumptions for instance of the cost
which is actually important in many
machine learning applications
uh then
the the default approach to to handle
this would be to uh
to run a network flow simplex solver
which is a specialized form of uh linear
program for network flows
and
this is typically a super cubic
complexity worst case
complexity and you can also observe
empirically that this is this goes
cubically
and so on the one hand
remember that this p star already has
size
n times m
so what this tells you is that you have
a variable set which is size n m
you would need nm square i mean let's
say a cube of that from square to cube
to optimize so that's already quite
quite
quite satisfactory similarly even if
you're solving the dual problem the dual
problem only has n plus n variables but
the constraint set is already also n m
remember that the
the the law also has a size of a
constraint which is quadratic so all in
all it seems to be a fairly reasonable
thing to to to hope
but
this is still a bit problematic in many
machine learning applications it's very
difficult to convince a practitioner
that that you have to go cubic in terms
of computations to
to to introduce a new tool so this is
more or less doomed to fail already and
this is why the this this earth moves
resistance as people called that in
about 20 years ago when he introduced
first
optimal transport ideas in machine
learning well this there was a bit of a
fashion and then after a few years it
faded out because the cost was just
too big to bear
let me just say another thing
which again another bad news in terms of
computations i believe
which is that if you look at this uh
linear program of first linear program
i've been around for like seven years
now so we we understand them very well
and it's it's it's it makes sense you
know to to compute the value of the
optimal value what we know though is
that the solution of optimal transport
or of network flow problems or linear
programs is extremely unstable and not
always unique
and so if i just go back to the initial
you know motivation of my talk remember
in biology
what people want to do is not
just you know find an optimal matching
per se to minimize the cost
they are interesting in the in the
argument itself they're not interested
just in the minimum value
which is the output of this linear
program they're interested in the
argument
and if you look at the argument
well imagine a little bit what this is
very classic you know linear programming
sensitivity analysis but imagine
a little bit what would happen if you
were to perturb a little bit the inputs
so here i'm going to perturb like this
is the primal problem i'm going to
perturb
x you know the locations of let's say
the
the the bakery
if i just perturb things it's a bit as
if i was you know changing a little bit
this this vector here
and so for a while what you can very
clearly see
is that
the solution even if you perturb it with
the inputs is not going to change
until the moment which never happens in
real life
where the cost is going to be orthogonal
to a facet of the polytope and then all
of a sudden what will happen in real
life is you will jump you know from a p
star to another star so if you go back
to the biology you know the matching
problem
it's very intuitive to see that
you know if you're looking at two
different point clouds and you perturb a
little bit a point cloud that for a
while you know the optimal matching will
stay the same
and then all of a sudden maybe a
really infinitesimal move will trigger a
switch you know between between the
between the
between the matchings so what this means
is essentially
is the jacobian
of p star with respect to
let's say dx
is either zero
or infinity
okay
and since most of machine learning today
is based on some form of gradient or
first order differentiation you can
immediately see a problem
if you will need to focus you know to
rest to use this p star in your
machine only pipe
so
first this means that the objective
itself the minimum is not differentiable
everywhere
so there are some some basically some
breaks
but what is
i think more problematic is that the arc
mean itself
is not is is technically differentiable
almost everywhere but its derivative is
zero almost everywhere
so this is the the the one of i mean
this is a list of you know negative
aspects of using the plug-in estimator
of optimal transport in machinery and
let me just add a
yet another one which is that
the complexity of those algorithms are
actually pretty heavy not complexity in
terms of
computation complexity but actually
implementing them running them on
parallel uh
architectures it's very difficult to
scale them properly
i think everything is kind of you know
working hand in hand if it's if it's
hard to implement in matrix or linear
algebra it's hard to differentiate and
it's hard to run on on gpus or or
parallel hardware so
everything is is more or less tied
so um
the other
uh
important criticism that people will
make towards
you know plug-in
estimation of optimal transport and here
again this will deserve an entire
lecture on its own
is
basically the idea that
optimal transport has to deal with the
curse of dimensionality
if you have dimensions is if you if
you're studying distributions which are
in dimensions five or ten you will
already start hitting this problem which
is that to have a good estimation of the
optimal transfer between two densities
using samples you read an exponential
number a number of samples that is
exponential in dimension
to to have a good quality of the
approximation so let me just very
briefly mention this because there's a
there's a
whole body of work on this
and i'm not the most qualified person to
to to discuss it but this has been uh
driving a lot of you know research
interests and statistics i know philippe
has been working on ideas related to
this or trying to for instance find
pounds on covering the mojo but other
people have been working also on trying
to you know add some
conditions on or hypothesis on the on
the on the smoothness of the densities
to to get better better rates
but anyway the the my main message here
is the picture is a bit bleak
if you just stick you know to the
to the gospel i would say of of more
than control it
so
the what i want to basically
motivate here
is that if you
are interested in optimal transport and
you want to be a bit opportunistic and
think
that you want to apply this to to to
real life problems what you're going to
have to deal with is those those two
aspects
computationally it's it's
fairly heavy if you really really take
the the controversy definition
i haven't really talked about the more
definition because usually it's it's a
bit less relevant in
in stats
the jacobians are zero or infinite if
you look at the arguments and this is
one of the you know reasons why people
use optimal transport this idea of
matching
and statistically it's a nightmare
everybody knows that this is really not
a a good
a
good a good place to be
to estimate this quantity
so
my my main message here is that if you
want to use these ideas in data science
you somewhat have to adapt them you need
to
add add some kind of you know learning
uh
perspective on this you have to
impose some kind of prior
inductive bias people call this and so
somewhat you just need to regularize the
optimal transport problem to improve on
either or preferably both aspects
and so
again since there's at least three
canonical formulations for optimal
transport the dual cantalovich the
primary controversy
you can see there's lots of
opportunities here for creativity
and to start you know uh
changing tweaking things to to introduce
some some prior so one of the obvious
things is when you start running you
know the
the dual catalyst problem and you want
to run this on on on functions
you will restrict your space of
potentials to something which is
has some properties so this could be an
rkhs of functions and so this has been
uh used uh for a few years now there's a
very interesting recent work
by uh
by a former colleague a student of mine
and francis back and also rudy
a lot of people that was published and
called this year
the other important thing
to know
uh i guess you you talked a bit maybe i
didn't
do details about c convexity in the
previous lectures but
what
you might know is that if you
instantiate the optimal transport
problem
uh when the cost is a distance
then the dual formulation has a simpler
form it is very nice it is basically the
super member of our limpiest functions
it's like an integral probability metric
so it's super number of linear functions
of the
the the the test or the integral of the
function on the differences of the two
of the two densities
so in that case uh people have
there has been a big broom you know in
machine learning by optimal transfer
thanks to this western guide paper
who basically introduced the idea of
parameterizing those
one lip sheets functions as neural
networks
with rectified linear units and and
constraints on the on the weights so
this was a
a fancy way to parameterize one
lipschitz functions and then run
you know standard
stochastic gradient
ascent to to to to to to minimize to
optimize this
there are some other
results that apply but in lower
dimensions you see wavelet
decompositions then let me just also
mention some
some nice recent uh
works that
use a specific class of uh neural
networks that are convex
with respect to to to their input so
they they're called input convex neural
networks so you might wonder why input
convex well it's because they are convex
with respect to the x and not with
respect to parameters theta that form
them so this is a
just a
naming
thing so if you uh compute the vasa
strain distance and so the optimal
transfer problem between two measures
when the cost is the the squared
euclidean distance
okay
then you can also parameterize the dual
problem
as a super member of a class of convex
functions where you're going to
introduce
the uh legend uh conjugate of the of of
the function f and so in that case what
people have been doing is uh introduce a
class of neural networks for this family
of functions f and then they do tricks
to to more or less approximate the f
star
so
this is this is recent work
you can also try to regularize the
primal optimal transfer problem again i
want to stress that
everything is for grabs in the sense
that you know
you just take the the original
definitions that just try to
to adjust to change things so that they
suit better your application so people
of course have started thinking about
changing the cost somewhat
making it
simpler so one
immediate way of doing it is
thresholding it or assuming that the
cost is the shortest distance uh
shortest path distance
on the graph or things like that this
simplifies the computations a lot
even in the lp case
the other thing you could think about is
if you're giving me two measures i'm
going to project them on a set of
densities or measures so typically this
could be
approximating a measure by a gaussian
and then using close form formulas for
the options
this could be using k-means if you have
a lot of points
and then compare the two uh k-means
distributions do quantize distributions
rather than comparing the two
distributions directly
there's also a trend which is to project
the measures first on a smaller subspace
and then copy the optimal transfer in
that smaller substrate there's lots of
ideas and there's one that i'm going to
talk a bit more in particular in the
last minutes or so which is about
entropic regularization
and so the idea oh let me just
very briefly mention the idea that you
can also try to regularize the morse
problem
and this
essentially is also using the bronier
theorem which tells you that it for the
most problem when the cost is critically
existence
uh you know that the optimal transport
is in the gradient of the convex
potential of the convex function sorry
and therefore you can try to
find
the convex
input convection network
whose gradient when you push it forward
to mu
makes it look
as close as possible as new as you can
and so if you
if you depending on what you mean by
clothes
you will have different types of
algorithms so
recently we've been exploring the idea
of actually using a
a
form of sample
a sample based uh delta for
for the versatile distance between the
two those two measures people have also
used the kubernetes divergence and and
place themselves in the framework of
continuous normalizing flows this
there's a lot of ideas out there but i'm
sorry this is a bit of a accelerated you
know
mention of all this let me just focus on
one which i've been working on a lot on
in in recent years
so the motivation for um foreign
organization essentially goes back to
this you know geometric picture of
trying to solve this linear program
and the wish list for this is to have
something that is more scalable that is
more stable
and differentiable automatically maybe i
will explain later what i mean by
automatically but differentiable with
respect to the input such that in the
sense that if i'm able to find something
that is here
that i would call my
my p star somewhat maybe not the optimal
one but something of this slightly
different definition
but that this p star is easier to
compute this p star so let me just put a
gamma in front of it so that i explained
that this is my
this is a different a different uh
notion of p star
i would want basically this thing to be
differentiable with respect to whatever
i want
and i would want this p star gamma to be
relatively cheap to compute
and
the way to get there
is essentially to
introduce regularization in the linear
program
and here
i just want i will introduce this in the
primal setting
in the primal setting you have this
linear objective linear constraints you
just have this gamma times entropy of p
this is an idea that it dates back to
the 60s in economics
and if you just add this gamma times
entropy you are essentially adding a
gamma strongly convex regularizer minus
three gamma entropy a gamma strongly
convex
uh regularizer on this on this polytope
and by here what i mean by it is just
the classic shannon entropy and what you
observe is that if you add this
regularizer
the spirit of this regularizer
essentially is to go further away
from the mosh problem still more so
somewhere there is a hierarchy where the
most problem remember
maps one point to another
the carton of each problem introduces
couplings to allow you to map one point
too many but usually
in practice you might
map only one point to a few if you're in
the discrete setting what we want to do
here so this is what would happen with
the gamma is equal to zero so no
regularization
so you have contour which are more which
really look alike in this set in this
setup
when you increase gamma essentially you
want to have more entropy
and what it means to have more entropy
is to have more blur
and the blur you want it to be in areas
typically
because this is regularizer where you
don't want to trade off too much cost so
you will start seeing blurs appearing
in areas where you're not really
impacting too much the cost and when
gamma goes to infinity
essentially you're left with the
coupling which has maximal entropy and
that's just the product of the two
margins
let me
now focus a bit on the on the
computational side of this
why is that
an approach that is that is popular
it's essentially because if you just
write the first order of the conditions
for this problem so i'm going to be a
bit fast here
please i apologize for this but if you
just write the first order conditions
for this problem so this regularized
linear program
what you realize is that the optimal
transport matrix this p star gamma p
gamma here has a very specific form
it is a
it is factorized as a diagonal matrix
times a matrix k and then another
diagonal matrix
so this makes it
you know makes this
coupling very specific in the sense that
it needs to be factorized as two
diagonal matrices left right and then in
the middle of this matrix k and this
matrix here actually is given to you
it's just simply the exponential of
minus
the cost matrix that that you
represented earlier
so
this is just first order conditions just
very simple consequence of
elementary principles but what this
provides you is a factorization for the
matrix
which then
you can also explain the fact that this
matrix is in the uh set of constraints
you know that that we we are given
are the row sums and column sums and
this yields a very simple algorithm
which is called the second algorithm so
essentially the
the regularized optimal transfer problem
here consists in finding the u and the v
such that this matrix here
satisfies the marginal constraints a and
b
so if you just work it out
using really elementary calculus you
realize that you want this matrix to
have row sums a
and column sums b so you're taking the
transpose here
so if you just do a few steps you know
the limitary computations what you end
up finding out is that you need to have
a u and a v
which satisfies those this fixed point
equation
you want u that is equal to a divided by
k u v sorry and v which will equal to v
b divided by k transpose
this algorithm is actually very easy and
very trivial to implement and people
have been studying it
uh for for decades now and there's been
a bit of a
surge of interest in this algorithm in
recent years
because of its applicability to optimal
transfer problems and so we understand
quite well it's it's convergence right
now
and we
in many cases we can actually make the
most of it you know to make it scale to
to large sizes of points
so let me just
make a brief parenthesis here to mention
that
here i just derived this
synchronous algorithm
by focusing on the primal optimal
transport problem regularized primal
this is a convex problem so it has a
dual the duo is simply this thing here
and it's interesting to compare the dual
of this regularized problem with the
dual of the original team crossbow
problem essentially what happened is
that
the constraints that we had here
remember in the dual problem
the constraint that told you that alpha
i plus beta ij had to be smaller than
the cost
x i yj have disappeared and they became
a big regularizer here
and
again i don't want to d just to
demystify a bit this synchro algorithm
it's essentially just block coordinate
descent
on this dual problem here
so let me just skip a little bit i have
a few slides to explain the interaction
between this quantity
that you can define using the
regularized optimal transfer problem
like my p star
compared to using the troop star
and
coupling which would be the
maximally entropic coupling i'm going to
skip this
because i want to reach the end
which is now i'm going to focus in the
last minutes on the differentiability
of this of the vassar's time distance or
the optimal transport
this optimal transport criterion
and
later on on the optimum matching itself
so
let me just explain a bit by me my
differentiability here because this this
has several this could be several
meanings
one of the first things that you can
think
is
what happens you know when you have
these two distributions when i'm going
to modify the weight of the first
measure
so this is one source of
differentiability that you want to to to
understand so by this i mean imagine i
change a little bit you know the
typically the the perturbation would sum
to zero so that uh the the the the
weight vector a is still equal to sub to
one
so what i want to know is basically
how will this vassoshtein distance vary
as a function
of this delta a right
and if
the other way to you can vary basically
the
the optimal transfer problem of course
is
by changing the locations
so by this i mean adding a delta x here
which is going to change switching to
middle locations
so
the
what i want to really insist here is
that
if the only thing you want to find out
is how the wasserstein distance or the
optimal transport criteria itself will
change
with respect to changes in the weights
or the locations
essentially this is
this is always going to be a result of
the danskin's theorem
which tells you that
you're basically let's say writing
something which is going to be f of a is
equal to a minimum
of g of a and x okay
and x is in a set
and then this is more or less going to
be equal to g of a comma x star
if x star is the argument and so
how f is going to vary with respect to a
is more or less how this function would
vary with respect to a
you more or less freeze you know the
the optimal solution and then pretend
things change that way so if you do that
either with the weights or the locations
everything is easy
so i have slides here to explain this in
more detail especially with the when the
cost is quality a distance but if you
just
think about what i just told you you
just run the dual optimal transfer
problem with the prime optimal transfer
problem you solve p star or the dual
potential star and you freeze them
and then you just differentiate the
objective function of the optimal
transport problem
this is a different story now if you
want to differentiate with respect to p
star so here for instance again what i
want to illustrate is that
this differentiability is basically
going to focus on the difference between
the objectives
okay
so computing this difference between the
objective is going to be easy so here by
this square i'm basically meaning any
input variable of interest
so this could be the measures themselves
uh
some parameter which which parameterizes
represent representation of your list of
your points
uh parameter for the distance parameter
for whatever
basically you you will always be able to
fall back on your feet
what is going to be more difficult
is differentiating this p star and as i
said earlier here in this case maybe
here this is this is so difficult that
it's trivial
this is just going to be zero but if you
want to be able to to to differentiate
this p star
you will need to go a bit deeper into
mass so there's two ways you can
actually do this in a
in a meaningful way
the first one is to if you look at the
regularized perspective that i just
mentioned
is to look at this from a programmer's
perspective so what does a programmer
see when i describe the sinkhole
algorithm
the sinkhole algorithm is just a
sequence of operations which starts from
a simple initialization
go through a loop of
updates
and then in the end return whatever
estimate they had of the optimal
transport matrix at that vote
if you
program this
if you're able to program it in
elementary steps like this then you are
able to differentiate it automatically
with any of the automatic
differentiation uh frameworks such as pi
torch jacks or tensorflow etc
so i would say this
if you want
an even more crude you know
example of this you could almost think
of this as a neural network that you
have parameterized completely in terms
of
what each layer is doing you just give
it data
the data feeds
creates a data matrix a distance matrix
distances matrix is turned into a kernel
matrix and then you just run you know
the synchronous loops which are
uh limit twice uh matrix vector products
and animation operations and then this
outputs a matrix
so this was actually leveraged in
several papers in in recent years
and it actually works quite well but
there are some documented issues with
with uh with automatic differentiation
one of them being that this can have a
very large memory footprint the other
one
that i i would like to to bring forward
is more i would call it a mathematician
view
and i'm to to describe that i'm going to
use this
regularized optimal transfer problem in
the dual
so remember i introduced
regularized optimal transport as you
know minimum of p
comma c minus gamma entropy
sorry
entropy
of p and i told you this is the primal
and the dual is this thing which is
basically this thing here
well i'm using the dual because it's
simpler because it's an unconstrained
optimal it's an unconstrained convex
optimization problem maximization
problem so
basically gradient descent or gradient
ascend here should work at some point
and first order conditions are trivial
to to characterize so this is the energy
that my optimal transfer problem in the
dual is going to optimize
and here i've been careful to keep track
of everything you know that is included
somewhere in my in my computation in the
energy
what i know and what the synchro
algorithm is going to do is essentially
cancel those two gradients one after the
other the gradients with respect to
alpha and the gradient respect to beta
which i have here in close one
now
i'm going to just simply introduce
something which is a vector a valued
function h
which will take all of those
inputs
and it's going to just
produce the the values of those two
gradients
and what i know is that this function h
if i have to evaluate it at the alpha
star and beta star this should be zero
i'm just saying here that the gradient
of a convex optimization problem at
the optimal solution is zero
so to sum up
i have
i can imagine you know my optimal
transport routine is a mapping that
takes inputs measures cost to
regularization parameter whatever
and outputs
dual optimization variable as we saw
earlier
sorry hey i'm doing well over here
so i'm sorry i hear a voice
okay
so uh
the the this mapping is basically taking
whatever you gave you know this optimal
transport routine and now putting the
solution here i'm focusing on the dual
dual variables
um what i know
if i store you know the gradient so this
is the gradients of the energy with
respect to alpha
with respect to beta
which turned out to be and this is
quite nice
the marginals of the matrix that that
you get at that moment for the alpha
beta but let me just
please ignore this for a second
what i know is that if i inject the
optimal solutions to this h function
then i should have zero because this
just simply means that i
have reached the optimum
so what i have is basically a root
of this h function
and our goal is to compute variations of
f variations of the optimal transport
solutions
with respect to any of the inputs
and the way to do this canonical of
course is to use the implicit function
theorem
so the implicit function theorem is just
going to tell you that
this output
varies as a jacobian as any input here
i'm calling this a black square
in the following way this is the the
actually the actual uh
the the
the formula it's going to be the
jacobian of this root function here
first of the conditions function we
expect to whatever input variable you're
computing evaluated at that variable in
alpha star beta star
and then you will need to do an inverse
which is going to be on the jacobian
this time with respect to the
optimization variables so this is what
you have
let me just conclude to say that in
machine learning typically we are not
interested in just computing the
jacobians of something per se
we're interested in computing the
gradient of a loss which might depend
on this r minimum so if you go back to
the biology example
essentially we have a loss function that
will depend at some point on the optimal
mapping or matching that we that we
carried out
and we want to be able to compute the
gradient of that loss with respect to
some parameters
then if you if you know about this uh in
the the reverse mode of differentiation
then you know that what really matters
is not so much instantiating this huge
jacobian because that would be a waste
of memory and time
what you really need to do and the only
thing you want to do is to be able to
apply the transpose of this jacobian to
any vector
and so
this
is basically what what what you would do
in if you don't want to go you know this
automatic differentiation route
people call this unrolling also if you
want to do implicit differentiation
basically you just start from
this implicit function theorem that
tells you that this is jacobin you
transpose it
and you apply it to z vector z
and then you're wondering this is a huge
and horrible formula
is there any way someone can take care
of this for me
because in theory this should be
actually
already known to the program well there
is
this jacobian here and its transpose you
can instantiate it using typically
routines you know like a jax jvp
jacobian vector product the linear solve
system is going to be used handled with
typically conjugate gradient here
because the matrix is positive definite
and then this latest application of yet
another jacobian transpose is typically
handled with
the jack's vgp as well
so
i'm a bit running a bit over time i
started a few minutes late but so i'm
going to end
many minutes late sorry
just to say uh so the message here is if
you want to differentiate through this
optimal transport
and you are interested in this implicit
differentiation but you don't want to
know too much about it
uh you want to know too much about the
details themselves then
you could try this this toolbox that
we've been developing because this is
precisely the type of female challenges
that we've been covering in the toolbox
and so just to illustrate this you can
very easily compute phrases the hessian
of the optimal transport distance
between two point clouds respect to
weights this is automatically computed
for you without you having to
to write anything
so this concludes my talk i'm sorry for
being a few minutes over time
my main message is
you know optimal transport theory is
there
uh if you want to apply it to data we
need to regularize in a way or another
uh and i believe that this
regularization should not only cover the
idea of computing the distance itself or
the optimal transport but also be able
to be differentiable friendly
and i here i present two two canonical
ways of doing so
for the in the case of the entropic
regularization
i think there are other types of
regulations where you could try to do
that as well thank you
so thank you very much mark for this
very nice talk
is there any questions
yeah can you give a concrete example of
differentiating through the uh
why you would want to differentiate
through the star or the i mean
yeah so
so this is a very good this is a very
good question
so uh typically one one i mean there's
i would say this is a bit the you know
the the the bleeding edge of uh working
in applied
applying optimal transporting algorithms
but one of the
very classical problems in the game that
i that i that i provided earlier is this
idea of optimal matching
at some point you know your algorithm is
going to take as an input some some data
it's going to match it
to some references that you know are
important to you and this matching is
maybe parameterized by something
typically that may be parameterized by a
representation of your data or a cost
you know a matching cost and then from
there you will use this representation
next
to
let's say
define a classification rule or
something like that so it's it's very
common for instance in let's say
images patches you know you will need to
do some kind of matching between some
patches and some concepts that you have
one
idea that we've been exploring uh in the
last years or so is also the idea of
sorting
differentiable sorting or ranking
the idea that
ranking you know values real values is
the same thing as doing an optimal
matching between values on the real line
and integers
and so there also we need to have some
form of differentiability of this
of this ranking step
so
i would almost even claim that
all of the works that have been using
optimal transport so far
uh i've been doing this
by assuming that the cost structure is
known
so typically for instance in your in
your in your work in biology you would
project you know the data to pca
dimension 30
and then from there run you know optimal
transport and
and start that the cost is given if you
were to think about
is there a mechanism that would help me
learn the cost structure so such that
maybe some n metric you know some end
results of an error is improved
then you will need to differentiate
through this matching
okay
so all the questions
yes the second question
yes please
you mentioned earlier that uh the
optimal transport uh computation uh
it suffers from uh parts of division of
dimensionality and that's why um people
usually like uh regularize and uh you
introduce like several regularizations
i'm just wondering like um
with the regularization of how much game
do you get uh from this like statistical
guarantee
uh so
so there's lots of work so so typically
if
you use a tropic regularization you know
that
you fall back on some kind of one of the
square root n type of uh type of bound
as opposed to this exponential
number of samples but
i would say that everything is a bit
tied in
if you
if you have you know statistical
instability
due to the the this curse of
dimensionality you typically will
recover it
when you're going to optimize through
optimal transport because you will have
very unstable matchings that will that
will guide your learning process and so
you also observe this
you know when when you when you start
regularizing that it so much stabilizes
the learning process
so
so one of the problems with
regularization
however is that you start introducing a
bit apples and oranges
so so so if you if you start looking at
for instance the
the sample complexity of regularized
optimal transport ventricularization
that you're not looking anymore at the
the true optimal transport
and so so so i think this induces a lot
of different viewpoints on the same
problem
so i don't think there's any easy answer
to to your question
okay
yeah so
it's probably a naive question
reflecting my lack of knowledge of the
need for differentiability but so you
know you have this auto div which is
basically auto differentiating through
your code and you don't even have to
actually understand what a derivative is
do this
and uh so
why and you seem to be advocating that
we should actually build differentiable
procedures one at a time
is there no hope to actually think that
in three years from now they will have
smooth and auto smooth and auto diff and
they will just smooth everything that we
get and just auto dip through it i mean
like
yeah so so
i think
i think there's so okay maybe one one
quick way of answering this is
so few years ago machine learning was
all about you know uh gradients
and uh autodesk killed this somewhat you
know if you were good at computing
gradients you're useless
my impression is that right now uh what
you can be useful for is computing those
jacobins vector products
or vector jacobian products
uh because
essentially this is like the second
order somewhat you know of of of uh
auto this is something that autodesk or
enrolling is
is not very good at
so typically when you would run you know
this iterative process that would output
a solution
if you run autodiff naively
in theory you would need to store all of
the iterates
this can be very costly in terms of
memory so there are lots of
different approaches to to to kind of
mitigate this the storage or
computational problem so there's lots of
you know truncated back propagation
or uh implicit differentiation the way i
presented it here today and they are
actually quite linked
uh and so uh
it is a bit you know next front and it's
not soft you know trivially by other
lift that being said
what you said is true i i anticipate
that within three or four years
all of those
sensitivity analysis of art means for
instance will be more or less solved
what will still remain though
is what kind of uh
smooth or or um i would say
differentiable interpolation you
advocate for given problem
here for instance the optimal transport
problem clearly
you have a linear program that outputs
the solution
synchorn or i mean atropic realization
deviates a bit from that to give you
more smoothness more differentiability
and something easier to compute
it's not always the case i mean there's
not i don't think there's a
one-size-fits-all answer for all
optimization problems
to to to have automatic
both something that is uh uh
automatically and differentiable
automatically differential uh you you
still need i think to to to work a bit
on what what you
what you what kind of differentiability
you want to get out of of this
optimization
maybe i'm clear i'm um yeah yeah you are
here thank you okay
yes because michael could you could you
show again this formula for the jacobian
that you had
yeah
so i mean i suppose that you have to
input alpha star better start so this is
like the optimal
you know like dual variables but now
in practice you will have to evaluate it
at the you know along the sinkhole
iterations so i'm just wondering if it
matters and how much it matters that you
you know when you compute that horrible
formula that you're not evaluating it at
the actual alpha star
ah yeah so this is a very good very good
very good very good
question so this is the very classic
trade-off you know that you have when
you
when you have this you want to
differentiate when iterative algorithm
it's either use auto diff
differentiating exactly you know 100
iterations
or you run this to convergence
i mean hopefully and then as you said
this is only valid if really alpha
started beta star basically this is only
valid if
this thing here is zero right this h
here is zero because this is
this is the the reason why you can use
the implicit function here you have a
zero on the right hand side and so when
you when you so uh i'm not uh
i think there are some works to tell you
truth i'm not familiar enough with them
in the literature that tries to estimate
how uh how much noise you would get in
the application of that jacobian
using this formula if alpha star and
betas are not exactly optimum
i i guess this would typically depend
you know on the on the eigenvalues of
the jacobian matrix at the at the
optimum
and so so i i i haven't gone deep into
the literature if i can just provide you
a hands-on
perspective on this
um
typically what you would do is set a a
threshold with zincon it's a fairly
simple problem right this is a convex
problem so you will run to you you can
you can dictate if you want the
threshold
of convergence so typically you would
you would use a small threshold for
convergence here to make sure that the
implicit function theorem works and then
what we do is we compare this with with
backprop
and this this seems to uh to agree in
most cases one of the sources of
problems though
it seems to me is not so much from the
alpha star beta star because this is
controllable but it's more of the the
inverse of the linear system
so the linear system can be ill
conditioned
and so then just you start adding some
regularizations and things like that
you
so i also have a question marco can you
say something about like advantages of
using other types of entropies other
than like the channel entropy i don't
know the quadratic or the sales
yeah so in particular sorry in this like
uh
implicitly differentiation
do you really use like the exponential
shape of the the solution or it would
work in principle forever regularization
yeah so this is a very good question so
so for a while i guess my position on
this is because i was relying more on on
on the back prop on unrolling
i
i was favoring somewhat entropy because
i thought the the algorithm you know
synchro environment to get you the
solution was extremely
stable and very very effective
and so i was using the classic scene
corn and then unrolling iterations of
the castings in corn but as you just
mentioned
if you start using a different
regularization in the end the only thing
that you really need to
take into account is first order
conditions of your problem if the first
order conditions of your problem
can be i mean this is just a jacobian
here of h with respect to the the black
back square
if if if this is a linear system that
you can solve then in theory any
regularizer should work so this includes
for instance let's say quadratic which
is known to provide a sparse
approximation or solid central extra i
still believe that it's going to be
difficult to beat
synchorn when you're going to run the
forward pass so we're going to reach to
alpha star beta star
but you can now at least
start using
without thinking too much about
unrolling you can start using like a
momentum based approaches or
recently i've been playing with
playing with momentum and also what is
the other thing that i i played a bit
with anderson acceleration which didn't
work for me at all
uh and uh
sorry i forgot the other one
anyway so uh
but i i agree with you that
you switching to a
implicit function theory by opposition
to unrolling gives you more freedom
but do you see like any context where
like use another entropy could win the
channel one
yeah
so i i think still you know the
factorization of the coupling is always
going to be very useful
i i have the feeling that
in practice you know uh this gives you a
lot of uh opportunities for speeding for
speed up you're probably familiar with
with many works you know that use
factorizations of the of the kernel or
of the couplings
so i still believe in that sense entropy
is actually
quite good but
recently for instance we've been playing
a bit and this follows a bit the
follower follow-up work on some work by
philip as well
on the low rank
low rank couplings and indeed in that
case what you would you could also think
is just differentiating them without
without so much caring for entropy
so yeah i think it's a it's the the
question is open
we're open for i mean for me at least
it's more open now than it was maybe
three years ago
thank you thank you marco
so i guess it's time to leave you relax
no thank you very much for
the tough
so we resume at four
and good luck to jan
yeah it's a bit late for jan right
yes yes
so i don't know if we can really do that
to him uh
i think it's a bit too late to tell him
now because i'm pretty sure he maybe we
could take like a you know 10 minute
break and then come back in 10 minutes
so young is already online right jan
yeah yeah i'm here i'm still awake okay
one more hour
so let's do 10 minutes and we come back
is it fine